a eu urencontre de l'OTAN.
Mélanie Joly, ministre des
affaires étrangères, et avec
nous ce soir. Bonsoir.
-
- Avant d'aller dans les
avez-vous pu cela la nuit
dernière?
- C'est sûr qu'on avait du
renseignement qui démontrait
allaient commencer. Ils allaient
commencer vers 10 heures le
soir. Et c'est à peu près au
moment où ils ont commencé. J'ai
été en contact par la suit
notre sous-ministre, mais aussi
place. Vous voyez depuis
temps déjà on avait de
pouvait être une cidododododonc
j'avais pris la décision avec
mon équipe de boug
effectifs de l'ambassade qui
avant la ville qui était plus à
l'ouest, plus proche de la
frontière avec la Pologne. Et
donc au milieu de la nuit, cette
nuit, j'ai eu l'occasion de
reparler encorrererererere
ambassadrice. La délégation
canadienne au grand complet
soutenait également la
délégation de la Suède qui avait
besoin d'aide. Et donc ensemble,
avec mon autorisation, ils ont
décidé de quitter la ville e
d'aller en Pologne.
- Et pour les ressortissants qui
sont toujours en Ukraine
vont tenter de sortir par la
route, comme les autres?
- Oui, l'objectif, c'est que si
vous avez la famille ou des amis
en Ukraine, allez sur le site
Web du gouvernement, sur les
médias sociaux. Mais bien sûr,
il y a des bombardements, on
vous demande d'aller
endroit sécuritaire et bien
entendu d'être capable de
quitter le pays à partir du
moment où jus p p p p p p p plus
sécuritaire. Mais pour
l'instant, on a aussi des
effectifs dans tous les quatre
pays limitrophes
J'ai pris des ententes, mon
équipe et moi avons pris des
ententes avec la Hongrie, la
Pologne, la Sl
Roumanie. J'ai eu aussi des
pourparlers avec la Moldavie.
Donc basé là-dessus, on sait
qu'on peut avoir certainement de
l'aide de l'autre côté de la
frontière ukrainienne.
- Je le dis nenenenenenenene le
savent pas encore, mais la
communauté ukrainienne
canadienne et la plus grande à
l'extérieuIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIlIl y a
1,3 millions de Canadiens
d'origine ukrainienne au pays.
Je vous montre un tableau... ce
qui étai C C C C C C C C Canada,
62 individus et entités russes
visées, ererererererererer de la
détruire, interdit de transiger
avec de grandes banques et
l'interdiction d'exporter en
Russieststststststststst
suff v v v v v v v v v voix on
dit que ce n'est pas suffisant.
Est-ce que c'est suffisant?
- Ce que je rajouterais à votre
taoioioioioioioioioiois pas
malheureusement, c'est que
toutes les grandes banques
russes qui sont touchées.
l l l l l l l l l le ministre s
Finances de la Russie, ministre
de la défense de la Russie.
ntntntntntntntntntnt, nous faiss
en sorte de consoler, d'annuler,
d'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'exportatione
biens qui sont importants pour
la Russie qui provient du
enenenenenenenenenent dans le
domaine de l'aérospatiale, dese,
et dans le domaine des minéraux.
Notre objectif, c'est vraimentsr
le régime de Poutine, étant
donné ce qu'il fait lui-même et.
- Mais les menaces de sanctions
avaient été télégraphiées, avais
empêché. Alors ça fera quoi?
- Vous savez, le but c'est
d'être uni, l'ouest au complet.
Vous l'avez mentionné en début.s
de l'Occident ont réagi. C'est t
c'est que les personnes autour
de Poutine, sa garde rapprochée,
soit affecté, justement, par la
réponse de l'Ouest, que les
Russes et l'économie russe soit
affaiblie. Et on pense, bien
entendu, que ça va déstabilisern
sorte d'affecter directement sai
auprès de la population. On sait
qu'il y a des mouvements
d'opposition en Russie. On sait
également que ces mouvements
d'opposition sont très souventaa
pression sur le régime russe,
puisqu'on est capable d'arriver
à nos fins.
- Là-dessus, de questions.
L'Europe a besoin du gaz russe,
de l'énergie russe. On a gelé le
gazoduc pour l'instant, qui
passe, qui a été construit.
Est-ce que votre ennemi
finalement, ce n'est pas le
temps, et qu'il y aura des
brèches dans la communauté
internationale, qui est sous le
choc aujourd'hui?
- Le prix d'une gare est
beaucoup plus grand que le prix
des sanctions. On a déjà eu ces
conversations en tant que
ministre des affaires
étrangères.
Deuxième point : on va faire en
sorte de mettre autant de
pressions possibles et, dans l
prochains jours, d'autres
sanctions vont être ajoutées.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un bon
départ. Le Canada un des p
importants ensembles de
sanctions du G7. Mais
c'est de rajouter d'autres
moyens, d'autres sanctions pour
faire en sorte de maintenir la
pression.
- Il y avait cette idée de les
bloquer du réseau Swiff.
Si tu n'es plus là-dedans, tes
banques ne peuvent plus faire
affaire av
on est pas allé jusque-là?
- Vous s
y a encore beaucoup d'options
sur la table. Le premier
ministre aujourd'hui à une
renc
de l'OTAN. J'aurais une
rencontre du G7 avec les
ministres des affaires
u u u u u u u u u u u u u u u ue
travailler ensemble.
On sait qu'il y a des vies
perdues, des bombardements qui
constituent, comme cette
responsabilité morale voir
exactement ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui.
- Et en terminant Mme Joly, ests
bras, faciliter l'arrivée
d'ukrainiens qui voudraient
arriver?
- Certainement. En planifiant le
tout, on savait qu'il pouvait ys
de personnes qui pourraient se
réfugier vers les frontières det
parti de l'union européenne.
C'est pourquoi nous avions fai